all right my talk of the table is a very
exciting announcement it's a new series
it's called kindness 101 and it is from
one of the best storytellers working
today our own steve hartman you may know
steve from friday nights and sunday
mornings his emmy winning series on the
road he's now sharing stories
out of the vault there built around
themes of kindness and character and the
people who have mastered both of those
qualities kindness 101 of course is a
good starter for discussions with kids
but we are confident that adults will
learn a thing or two as well and they
need to steve's first lesson
courage
good morning this is my daughter meryl
hi and today we're going to be talking
about how to get kids like merrell to
fail i did not expect that
you thought i would say succeed right
yeah yeah and i do want you to succeed
but before you learn how to succeed you
need to learn how to fail which is why
you need courage what is courage for
that let's check in with your brother
over at our dictionary desk damn it so
this essentially means like being brave
you would be able to
take up something completely new right
meryl do you remember for the longest
time you didn't even want to try riding
a bike
i was worried everyone would laugh at me
she was afraid that she would fall off
get injured could have broke your
clavicle
what's a clavicle yeah what is it
you know i'm gonna hook that
okay you look that up we'll go on
as you guys know i've interviewed some
of the best people this country has to
offer people who can teach us pretty
much everything we need to know to be a
better person
so this morning i looked in that library
of stories past and found what i think
is the perfect tale to teach us all how
to be a little more courageous
they were the bad news bears of swimming
y'all are in two minutes in fact coach
alex wiedemann of seguin high school in
arlington texas says you can't overstate
they're under achievement
our goal every meet was to finish the
race just get across the pool get across
the pool we measured our success on not
getting disqualified and because that
was the standard gerald hodges made the
team perhaps the only kid to ever make a
high school swim team without a clue
how to swim
he couldn't get across five yards let
alone 25 yards was there really nobody
better
no
come on gerald eventually he at least
learned how to not drown and even finish
some races albeit long after the other
competitors were done and toweled off
push it come on yes he was that bad
which is interesting oh because on dry
land gerald is a remarkable athlete
could you have made the basketball team
i think so soccer team
pretty positive
so why swimming i felt like if i
couldn't handle not being good at
something then how could i consider
myself you know a successful person
that quote bears repeating
if i couldn't handle not being good at
something then how could i consider
myself a successful person
to gerald setting yourself up for
failure is actually the key to future
success especially if you can somehow
manage to master your weakness
and by the start of his senior year
gerald had actually improved a lot
but no one really knew how much until
the big regional meet
it was the 200-yard medley relay top two
teams qualify for state
and as usual seguin was pretty much in
last place with 50 yards to go
and that's when gerald jumped in the
water
keep in mind at this level making up any
significant time is nearly impossible
unless maybe you've got something to
prove
unless maybe you've stared failure in
the eye and see it now for the paper
tiger that it is
whatever the reason the kid who couldn't
swim
just sent his team to state
man we was ecstatic i could barely
contain my energies i was trying to go
get this medal i'm sitting here just
freaking out you're having a hard time
now yes i was like
i've come so far
from now on whenever you think anything
is impossible
think of gerald
whenever you think the easiest path is
the best
think again
gerald had a profound impact on me and i
know you too
do you remember what you did right after
i showed you that story the first time i
thought i said i wanted to try riding my
bike the courage of this child yeah i
felt like i don't think i'm gonna do
this and then i didn't listen to that
look at this and i kept on trying
congratulations gerald is definitely an
inspiration
which is why i'm thrilled to see him
again hello gerald hi everybody so
you're a senior in college now and
you're a math major that can't be easy
being a math major is always difficult
so math didn't come naturally for you
not in college no i had to study a lot
more you should have just taken
something easy like swimming easy is
good for five minutes but for the future
hard is always a better option at least
from what i've learned
were you at all afraid to fail
yes i was definitely afraid being afraid
just means you have common sense um as
long as i didn't act on that fear i
didn't let that stop me from doing what
i wanted to
this guy's wise
he is wise isn't he i'm not wise but i
take my i listen to the wise people in
my life yeah all right gerald thanks so
much for talking to us no problem thank
you guys for having me
gerald inspired you
and hopefully you too
to let failure open the door to your
success
we'll see you next time until then
stay kind
steve
stay kind
that's the thing your stories have so
many levels number one i didn't think we
were going to see gerald and to see him
again oh my gosh he's doing great he's
doing something how could he not do
great i mean he's everything i want my
children to be yeah i actually invited
him to live with us you did i wanted him
to come to college near us because i
wanted my kids to have him as a role
model unfortunately his parents love him
very much
i did extend the invitation you do such
a good job of finding the absolute best
in people and then they in turn show you
their best and you share it with all of
us uh it's a beautiful thing and i'm so
excited for this series me too what do
you hope we just saw courage what else
might be in store for us we've got
lessons on determination empathy service
compassion basically everything you need
i think to be successful in life if you
have good strong character i've always
believed everything else falls into
place it doesn't matter if you know the
quadratic but steve the beauty of you is
sometimes even when you don't have good
strong character or it doesn't appear
you have good strong character you
always find a good story yeah
well i think there's good in everybody
you do i do i think has a question mark
you do i'd like to believe that no i
like that yeah yeah because i do believe
that we are more people want to do the
right thing and i do think more people
are good than not yeah i actually do
believe that i also think steve when i
saw
your daughter reacting to what she saw
with gerald as every every journalist
wants to have that kind of an impact if
it's not just on one person but many
people that they see something that you
report on and that you wrote and they
say i'm gonna do
better starting with that's what i want
to come from this i think this that's
that's the gift i want to give
i think you're giving it thank you very
much so great to meet you after six
years of the company watching you every
friday we were so excited you were in
there
and i love your son and daughter too are
we going to see them on a regular basis
in every episode
i love the dictionary
steve hartman it's so good you're here
thank you